we seem to mostly agree that murder is
bad the certain universals that seem to
emerge I wonder what the murder of an AI
is bad
well I tend to think yes but uh and I
think we're gonna have to contend with
that question
oh and I wonder what AI would say yeah
well I think you know one of the things
with with AIS is it's one thing to wipe
out that AI that is only you know has no
owner you can even easily imagine an AI
kind of hanging out on the on the you
know on on the internet without having
any particular owner or anything like
that
um and then you say well well what harm
does it you know it's it's okay to get
rid of that AI of course if the AI has
10 000 friends who are humans and all
those you know all those 10 000 humans
will be incredibly upset that this AI
just got exterminated it becomes a
slightly different more entangled story
but yeah I know I think that this
question about what do humans agree
about it's uh you know there are certain
there's certain things that you know
human laws have tended to uh
consistently agree about
um you know there have been times in
history when people have sort of gone
away from certain kinds of laws even
ones that we would now say how could you
possibly have not not done it that way
um you know that just doesn't seem right
at all
um but I think I mean this question of
what
I don't think one can say Beyond saying
if you have a set of rules that will
cause the species to go extinct
that's probably you know you could say
that's probably not a winning set of
laws because even to have a thing on
which you can operate laws requires that
the species not be extinct but between
sort of what's the distance between
Chicago New York
that Wolfram Alpha can answer and the
question of if this person is good or
not there seems to be a lot of gray area
and that starts becoming really
interesting I think your
uh since the creation of Wolfram Alpha
have been a kind of arbiter of Truth at
a large scale so this system is
generates more truth and try to make
sure that the things are true I mean
look it's a practical matter when people
write computational contracts and it's
kind of like you know if this happens in
the world then do this yes and this
hasn't developed as as quickly as it
might have done you know this has been a
sort of a blockchain story in part and
so on although blockchain is not really
necessary for the idea of computational
contracts but you can imagine that
eventually sort of a large part of
what's in the world are these giant
chains and networks of computational
contracts and then something happens in
the world and this whole giant domino
effect of contracts firing autonomously
that cause other things to happen and
you know for us you know we've been the
main sort of source the Oracle of of
quotes facts or truth or something for
things like blockchain computational
contracts and such like and there's a
question of you know what you know I
consider that responsibility to actually
get the stuff right and one of the
things that is tricky sometimes is when
is it true when is it a fact when is it
not a fact yes I think the best we can
do is to say uh you know we we have a
procedure we follow the procedure we
might get it wrong but at least we won't
be corrupt about getting it wrong so to
speak